[Musique]
sébastien arsac
bonsoir ça vous recevons aujourd'hui
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
thinker view ou reçoit dans votre cadre
de votre association qui s'appelle l214
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
donc je sui sébastien arsac je suis un
des co fondateurs de l'association l214
qui a été fondée par plusieurs personnes
qui date de 2008 à peu près on a effet
on est des militants à ces militants qui
ont fondé cette association donc qui
avaient fait leurs armes sur d'autres
campagnes
l214 c'est une association de protection
des animaux qui est spécialisé plutôt
dans les animaux d'élevage
donc les animaux qu'on utilise pour la
production de chair de viande pour le
lait pour les oeufs pour la peau pour
tous comptés in oui mais et puis avec
les eau ont fait du de la gélatine ferme
aujourd'hui on fait tout avec les
animaux et on est une association avec
une visée enfin abolitionnistes c'est à
dire que alors on est centrée sur les
animaux d'élevage parce qu'on considère
que ce sont les là où il ya une urgence
aujourd'hui au niveau de la protection
animale parce que c'est là où il ya le
plus d'animaux qui sont concernés avec
des méthodes d'élevage en général qui
sont très préjudiciables aux animaux
pour dire le moins et abolitionniste au
sens où on veut essayer d'alimenter le
débat autour de la question animale et
défendre l'idée qu'on n'est pas obligé
et que même c'est une injustice un
problème éthique d'utiliser les animaux
qui sont des êtres sensibles pour notre
consommation notre habillement voilà
donc on a à la fois un volet information
du public donc on va faire des enquêtes
dans les élevages pour essayer de
diffuser des images de des méthodes
d'élevage de transport d'abattage les
plus communes et par ailleurs on essaye
de
d'essayer de diffuser des idées ou des
arguments d'aller sur le terrain de
l'argumentation sur la question de la
place qu'on accorde aux animaux dans
notre société les autres animaux nous
sommes des animaux
mais voilà de l'espèce hominidés mais
voilà on veut défendre l'idée que la
question de la sensibilité et la
question cruciale sur le traitement des
animaux que vous connaissez la phrase
qui a d'engrenages de l'école de guerre
non on reconnaît l'évolution d'une
société à sa façon un ventilo de traiter
les animaux
oui voilà c'est ça je pense a dit pas
mal de choses effectivement et puis il y
à kundera qui disait que justement le
l'ultime test d'une pour juger d'une
société c'est l'attitude qu'elle a
envers les animaux justement qui sont
les plus faibles d'entre nous enfin les
autres animaux et ça ça se rejoint aussi
vous dis qu avant
alors moi pour je suis un campagnard
je suis né en auvergne au puy-en-velay
dans le 43 et mes grands parents sont
été éleveur beurre de coiffeur de bovins
vaches laitières en auvergne donc c'est
c'est polyculture et puis un peu
d'élevage à l'époque moderne
15 h 20 vaches et puis je suis un petit
peu à l'image de l'évolution de la
société française je pense qu'ils
étaient prêts agricoles
voilà 20e siècle et puis certaines
secteur tertiaire qui a évolué ça c'est
mes parents instituteurs ou secrétaire
et moi j'ai fait des formations
scientifiques de mathématiques et puis
je suis devenu professeur des écoles un
peu par hasard
pas longtemps et après je vois là j'ai
consacré aujourd'hui je consacre magie à
la question animale
comment vous vivez puis salariés
l'association maintenant l'association
l214 à la commencer donc en 2008 et on a
eu notre premier salarié qui ai moi-même
en 2009 j'ai d'être aujourd'hui donc on
a commencé on était pendant plusieurs
années on était payé au smic parce qu'on
n'avait pas le choix payer d'autres
choses avec des contrats aidés qui sont
en train de disparaître
et maintenant on essaye d'aller petit à
petit au salaire médian donc aujourd'hui
j'aurai 2000 euros brut
l'association l214 maintenant a évolué
énormément assez rapidement une
croissance à peu exponentielle qui va
sûrement arriver sur un plateau mais
aujourd'hui on est 40 salariés
on est tous payés au même salaire et
voilà c'est ça une présence sur les
réseaux sociaux qui est importante on
doit être plus de 650 mille personnes
sur la page facebook et on y arrive à un
moment donné où je pense que la question
de l'éthique des animaux de est un vrai
débat de société va cyber ciel est en
train d'approcher les a sûrement il ya
en tout cas au niveau de la consommation
quelque chose qui est en train de se
passer on voit que c'est la panique au
niveau des filières aujourd'hui qui font
tous d'or à l'assemblée générale sur le
sur le thème du bien-être animal et la
demande sociétale comme ils disent
poliment et timidement va dire plus tôt
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui il ya un vrai
dès lundi que naquit vega do s'est plus
jamais ça non mais c'est carrément fou
parce qu'on a des sociétés comme herta
fleury michon qui faisait des pubs pour
se [__] de la gueule des végétariens
qui aujourd'hui sont en train de voir
qu'il ya une demande et c'est un peu à
l'image de la société qu'on a
aujourd'hui capitaliste très productive
et c'est à dire qu'on peut avoir une
société antispécistes je lance le mot
qu'ils soient capitaliste et ultra
productiviste c'est c'est aujourd'hui
demain et société considère qu' il faut
faire du 100% végétale elles feront du
100% végétale donc c'est peut-être
quelque chose qu'il faut considérer
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui vous a produit
un déclic pour vous engager aussi
profondément dans l'action de protection
des animaux
c'est compliqué c'est sûr qu'on se pose
la question il ya une chose qu'il faut
dire c'est que
autant mois que l'ensemble des vegan les
antispécistes et tout ça sont pas des
gens exceptionnels
c'est juste sûrement quelque chose qui
est arrivé dans la dent dans sa propre
existence d question qu'on s'est posée
quand on a eu la chance de pouvoir se
poser aussi un moment dans sa vie qui
fait qu' on a fait un pas de côté sur
cette question alimentaire ça veut pas
dire que sur d'autres sujets
nous on n'a pas énormément de choses à
se reprocher moi je pense que ce qui a
été déterminant c'est la question de
déjà de vivre avec un chien en étant ado
ça veut dire qu'on voit que ce chien est
un individu et non pas un représentant
de l'espèce canine mais vraiment un
individu au sens croit que sa
personnalité qu'il est capable d'avoir
d'être triste d'avoir les explosions de
joie afin d'avoir des émotions c'est
tellement évident je pense à ces un
premier événement est le deuxième
événement je pense que c'est ma
la tuerie du cochon c'est à dire que
comme genre à l'ancienne ouais voilà
comme je disais tout à l'heure moi je
suis d'origine rurale
mon grand père était le seigneur n'a pas
seigneur est semer seigneur ait said
seniors du village c'est à dire c'est
lui qu'on appelait pour venir saigner le
cochon parce que tout le monde fait pas
ça à la campagne de tuer le cochon enfin
le fait de d'enfoncer le couteau est
donc chez mes grands parents je pense
que ce qu'on appelait la fête du cochon
c'est comme ça qu'on va l'appeler c'est
quelque chose qui m'a qui m'a sûrement
touché c'est à dire c'est le cri du
cochon qui m'a touché il faut imaginer
alors on est en train de créer on
critique souvent l'élevage intensif mais
juste pour décrire les conditions
d'élevage des cochons chez mes grands
parents c'était ce qu'on appelle dans la
sous- yard sait qu'apple un thermos
vergnas c'est une pièce fermée
donc ils voient jamais la lumière du
jour ils ont pas beaucoup d'espacé alors
ils sont pas sur un caillebotis béton
c'est la seule différence mais ils sont
alimentés avec les déchets enfin les
restes ou bacille de pommes de terre
cuites ou les choses comme ça et il voit
le jour que le jour où ils vont être
ligotée sur un char saignée sans aucun
étourdissements donc ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui méthode sans étourdissement
halal ou casher c'est ce qui se passait
pour les cochons en tout cas au moment
où moi j'étais ado dans la cour de la
ferme de mes grands-parents et le cri du
cochon il n'y a rien de plus rationnel
que par rapport à ce qui veut dire c'est
clair qu'il a envie de faire tuer je
suis pas s'il a la conscience de la mort
mais il sait quelque chose qui se passe
et
qui est pas forcément un avantage pour
lui ça se passe mal pour lui cette
panique ses émotions et c'est quelque
chose qui m'a qui m'a touché aussi je
pense
et puis le fait à la fois d'être à
cheval justement sur le monde rural et
d'en être sorti ça permet d'être un peu
libéré de déconstruire quelques choses
et d'autres moins dépendant d'une
situation
aujourd'hui on voit que les gens qui se
lancent dans l'agriculture sont souvent
des enfants d'agriculteurs le fils
d'agriculteur de file agricultrice je
pense qu'elles ont le normaliser une
situation et que c'est plus compliqué
quand on est dans cette situation de se
poser des questions sur la question
animale parce qu on a banalisé banaliser
le l'utilisation des animaux
on l'a vu récemment et vos vidéos etc
les poules et cochons les vaches et il a
un jeu les lapins
comment vous procédé comment vous
repérez un élevage ce qu'il y avait il
ya des whistleblowers des lanceurs
d'alerté au sein de ces élevages ou à ce
que dans tous les élevages ça se passe
comme ça alors on a différentes
situations en fait sont à des situations
très différentes
ça c'est arrivé qu'on se fasse embaucher
soit des gens qui se sont fait embaucher
pour travailler dans un abattoir
ça a été mon propre cas pour l'abattoir
de charal ça peut arriver aussi que des
gens nous fassent des signalements 1
parce que au fur et à mesure que
l'association a une visibilité
médiatique au niveau du public on est
devenu un peu la boîte à lettres d d d
alerte et j'ai envie d'enfin
dénonciation c'est au sens doléances des
doléances toute dénonciation c'est pas
un joli mot mais on est dans des
situations où il ya des animaux qui sont
à la merci d'un d'êtres humains dans un
rapport de force qui est complètement
c'est une espèce d'ingérence en fait je
vois ça comme une espèce d'ingérence
justifié dans les élevages ou dans les
abattoirs
donc on a des signalements comme ça
après c'est l'opportunité c
il ya plusieurs situations quand on est
sur l'espace public comme le transport
nous on peut faire des actions ou sur
les marchés aux bestiaux
quand on est sur les abattoirs c'est
plus compliqué donc ça peut être soit
des lanceurs d'alerté soit un relais où
nous même pas ça m'est arrivé la
dernière - l'abattoir 12 ans on
abattoirs des yvelines je suis moi même
avec un collègue rentrer dans l'abattoir
pour installer une caméra ça peut
arriver aussi le procès déjà là à votre
actif je n'ai pas à 15 20 30 procès
bayon en sont multiples ça c'est sûr
c'est la première premier réflexe des
filières c'est d'essayer de mettre des
moyens pour au niveau juridique c'est à
dire non mais en laissant les mains
propres
essayez de faire interdire les images
voilà on a eu des images interdites
et puis l'un des procès qu'on gagne mais
voilà c'est pas si évident mais c'est
une bataille la bataille juridique elle
est là elle importante
ça représente un investissement de
combien obtient pécunier au niveau de
votre association
au niveau juridique on a la chance
d'avoir deux avocates qui travaille pour
pas grand chose
donc chaque cas pour nous c'est juste
pas une quand on porte plainte c'est à
ces deux mille euros donc c'est pas
énorme
pour ceux qui connaissent les cochons ce
nom c'est le prix du travail des
avocates vraiment de caution mais après
on peut avoir des bonnes surprises comme
dans à peu près 50 50 qu'il vous êtes
près les jus ce que vous êtes prêts à
faire court et y aller jusqu'où pour ce
combat alors enfin sur les questions
c'est des questions stratégiques en fait
je pense plus que
que jusqu'où aller au sens donné de son
corps à prendre les armes on sait pas
quoi ce qu'elle n'a aucun intérêt
c'est vraiment des questions
stratégiques c'est qu'est-ce qui
fonctionnent le plus donc on teste des
choses on essaye de regarder ce qui se
fait à droite à gauche qui fonctionne
bien c'est un rapport de force
la question de l'élevage de faire
évoluer d'alimenter des questions de
percer au niveau médiatique de faim si
c'est une réflexion qu'on a sans arrêt
on s'est beaucoup basé sur notamment un
militant américain qui s'appelle henry
spira
qui avait été repérée par peter singer
qui a écrit la libération animale qui
est vraiment très important 1975 et on
respire a été un militant d'extrême
gauche qui voyait un pelé qui a vu un
peu tous les travers qui avait dans son
milieu militant l'origine mais qui en a
vu aussi les avantages et qui a donné un
certain nombre de pistes pour essayer
d'être efficace dans ses actions qui
sont notamment le choix des cibles
le fait d'aller alors à son époque
c'était aller discuter dans le bus avec
les gens pour voir où en étaient les
gens par rapport à la question animale
donc aujourd'hui ce serait peut-être
aller lire les commentaires facebook
donc après jusqu'où aller je pense qu'on
est on n'est pas dans une situation où
on peut imposer les choses on est dans
une situation
un débat démocratique democratic avoir
des arguments échangés
on a
aujourd'hui la chance d'avoir internet
les réseaux sociaux qui sont des
contre-pouvoirs qu'on n'avait pas il ya
dix quinze ans 15 ans où il y avait que
l'espace médiatique et puis c'est tout
que la télé la radio et journaux
aujourd'hui on a un vrai contre-pouvoir
donc c'est d'être présent sur ces
réseaux sociaux là et puis d'y passer du
temps à travailler avec intelligence
quoi c'est est ce que la question va
paraître trivial et bébé parce que la
police vous suit vous écoute vous repère
vous piste
vous avez remarqué oui une des choses
que je peux pas forcément produire mais
oui on sait qu'on est surveillé après
comme on a une activité qui est à part
la question de la collecte des images
qui peut être sujet à action juridique
et tout ça
on n'a pas d'actions enfin on essaie
d'informer la population enfin les
genres en deux époques bombe non non non
on ne sait pas trop notre but parce
qu'en fait enfin pour revenir un peu là
le coeur de l'it et le coeur voilà du
truc c'est que si on s'engage
aujourd'hui sur la question animale
c'est parce que on considère que quand
on réfléchit et ça c'est vraiment le
coeur de bouquins de la libération
animale et peter singer c'est de
réfléchir à qui on mais quels sont les
qui en fait inquiet au sens large au
départ on n'a pas la réponse et la
question justement qu'ils ont mais dans
la sphère d'égalité moral c'est-à-dire
au niveau des entités et des individus
quel est le critère pour considérer leur
intérêt pour les traiter bien ou pas les
considérer et si on considère que c'est
pas l'intelligence et c'est pas la
couleur de la peau si c'est pas le sexe
c'est pas le genre le sexe un mondrian
se pose mais quel est le critère finale
absolue enfin qu'on doit considérer dans
l'est dans la continuité des mouvements
de libération et droits civiques de
libération
de la femme etc et la conclusion est
moins de peter singer à laquelle nous on
adhère complètement c'est la question de
la sensibilité la capacité des individus
à ressentir le plaisir la souffrance à
avoir des émotions et si c'était
dangereux en train de système nerveux
central et ça et c'est pour ça que la
question je reviens à la question de
poser des bons pour nous un individu
humain c'est un animal comme un autre et
il y aurait enfin il y aurait quelque
chose qu'il n'irait pas avec notre
l'éthique qui et les seaux d'eau de la
douceur fin de la bienveillance envers
les individus qu'ils soient éleveurs
abattoirs ou employés d'abattoirs ou
quel que soit quelques métiers qu'ils
fassent même qu'ils soient liés à
l'exploitation animale etc
ce sont des individus qui ont leurs
raisons qui ont leurs histoires qui font
que ça les a menés là et poser des
bombes ce serait totalement
contradictoire avec la société dont on
rêve qui ne société pacifiée quoi douce
bienveillante et je pense qu'il ya
tellement de chemin avant parce que
c'est pas utiliser la force armée
c'est pas utopique société où tout est
beau tout est gentil violon se respecte
tout le monde
c'est une société vers laquelle on a
envie d'aller je pense que plein de gens
ont envie d'aller des syndicalistes ou
un vital et là les gens qui se battent
pour les droits de l'homme a envie
d'aller là et c'est pas du tout au rien
c'est à dire que même si on croit pas
que cette société soit possible dans
l'absolu aujourd'hui à une moyenne
échéance
ça veut pas dire qu'on ne peut pas aller
dans le progrès et
quant aux si on arrive par une campagne
à faire que il est plus de poules en
cages de batterie et ben c'est ça de
gagné quoi et ça veut pas dire que que
la situation à l'idéal pour les animaux
attention il ya la question de l'élevage
et la question de la prédation fait on
est dans un monde d'interdépendance de
souffrance et tout ce qu'on veut nous
milite pour un monde où la souffrance
diminue et dans l'idéal soi n'existe
plus mais on en est pas encore là c'est
des grands débats le troisième ministre
en humanisme aussi comme peuvent eux qui
posent ces questions là et mais ça veut
pas dire qu'il faut baisser les bras ou
que c'est ça ou rien quoi donc oui c'est
une utopie d'une taupe lycéens c'est une
horizon c'est quelque chose qu'on vise
quoi mais cette question de la
sensibilité elle est vraiment au coeur
de notre engagement et elle est
confirmée très régulièrement par les
recherches scientifiques un bon déjà
darwin un bouquin qui s'appelle
justement les émotions des animaux donc
il avait bien perçu ça qui avait pas de
différences flagrantes entre les autres
animaux et nous une patte différence
essentielle mais la perception de
grandes ligues
voilà c'est ça et aujourd'hui bain par
exemple il ya là la déclaration de la
conscience sûr que cambridge en 2012 qui
sont les plus éminents scientifiques
travaillent sur le cerveau et qui ont
conclu que les oiseaux et les mammifères
avait des substrats neurobiologiques
dans le cerveau
qui leur permettait d'avoir la
conscience on s'est même au delà de la
question de la souffrance et de la
douleur immédiate
donc on voit tous les jours au niveau
des théologies de la question de la
mémoire
la question des émotions et le monde
complexe le monde intérieur des animaux
en général mais les animaux c'est un
grand sac mais au moins des mammifères
des oiseaux est beaucoup plus complexe
beaucoup plus vieilles façons et en
parlant évolution que ce qu'on imaginait
est si fin des années 80 on opérait
encore les bébés humains sans
antalgiques
il ya c'est possible que dans quelques
années on s'aperçoive que la question de
la viande un des plus grands massacres
jamais planifié mon histoire humaine
prendre on a on évalue à peu près entre
90 et 120 milliards le nombre d'êtres
humains si on remonte à moins 50 milles
au moment des homo sapiens le nombre
d'êtres humains qui sont passés sur
cette planète
chaque année on tue 65 milliards
d'animaux terrestres quand votre
consommation humaine et plus de mille
milliards de poisson c'est pour dire à
quel point aujourd'hui on arrivait à des
sommes d'animaux qui sont utilisés pour
notre notre appétit gargantuesque notre
économie voilà on est je pense dans
l'histoire même de l'humanité
on n'a jamais eu une situation aussi
catastrophique à l'endroit des animaux à
cause de la consommation animale
alors quand une société plus en plus
pacifiée dans une relation qui ne tolère
plus au moins dans les textes en théorie
bien sur l'esclavagé qui va de plus en
plus vers l'égalité mais au niveau de la
question des mêmes qui se posent des
questions sur la question animale
de plus en plus mais la pratique est là
elle est un petit peu en arrière par
rapport à l'évolution des mentalités les
politiques qui vous perçoivent comment
ils vous perçoivent comme des bombes à
bas coûts qui peuvent servir à récupérer
des voix pour leurs campagnes où ils
vous perçoivent comme des ennemis qu'ils
les mettent en porte-à-faux avec les
industriels comment nous perçoivent les
politiques
c'est pas une question qui m'intéresse
énormément c'est comment les politiques
perçoivent la question animale qui
m'intéresse surtout et je pense que
peut-être ça que tu avais en tête quand
même des questions et alors jusqu'ici la
question animale était un peu absente du
débat politique et ça fait quelques
années qu'on tient à jour un site qui
s'appelle politique animaux et ils
pouvaient faire
ouais sûrement enfin si je filmais dans
un dans un moteur de recherche est le
premier premier sujet qui arrive et on
voit que cette question est en train de
monter vraiment de façon assez étrange
transversale d'ailleurs un que ce soit
c'est que c'est un sujet qui intéresse
plus qui on voit plus de politiques qui
sont intéressés au niveau de l'écologie
est au niveau
pas par exemple genre mêlant chants et
danses en campagne et enfin ça on voit
que l'extrême fin à l'extrême gauche à
la gauche
on va dire ça questions qui interpellent
on voit aussi des gens qui sont
sincèrement intéressé à l'extrême droite
par la question animale
et puis on voit des gens comme olivier
falorni qui est plutôt voilà parti
radical de gauche
des gens comme ça qui a beaucoup oeuvré
pour la question des abattoirs qui c'est
grâce à lui qu'il ya une commission sur
le sol et sur les animaux d'abattoir on
voit que c'est quelque chose qui
augmente de plus en plus par contre
quand on regarde une espèce de portraits
de l'assemblée nationale et encore pire
au sénat on voit que
les représentants avec plein plein de 10
mai sont pas si représentant justement
de la population et qui sont pas à
l'image des études d'opinion publique
qu'on fait que sont plus là pour pour
servir les intérêts particuliers privés
dans les territoires ruraux des
chasseurs de l'élevage voilà c'est plus
du clientélisme qui fait qu'il ya un
espèce de de situation qui n'est pas
représentatif de la situation
aujourd'hui de la considération pour les
animaux ont des envies de la population
face à ce sujet voilà c'est ça pour être
clair si j'étais pas très clair quant
aux vous est déjà arrivé d'aller
discuter qui a douché par hasard d'un
professionnel de l'abattage ou
professionnels de la viande comme une
discussion qu'on peut avoir à bâtons
rompus
comme lui vous perçoit à mon grand père
et mes grands-parents tenait une
boucherie donc réponse est positive
absolument il ya quelques semaines je
sais tu es sûr sur une interview fin
sera un débat avec hugo desnoyer kyelu
go desnoyers calé au boucher star à
paris un nouveau à ce soit au nom jeu
dans paris même je sais pas s'il a
plusieurs
plusieurs boucheries peut-être et
à la fin du débat il m'a filé sa carte
et là ya pas longtemps on a filmé
tribune pour demander l'interdiction des
cages des poules en cage et la cij j'ai
envoyé un mail à signer la tribune c'est
pour dire que oui on en avait on veut ya
des sujets qui sont évidemment on est
totalement il s'agit pas de dire on est
d'accord et on s'aime et on rit on lis
tout le discours non on est tout à fait
conscient qu'il serait question de les
tuer les animaux il ya un gap qui
soutient infranchissable mais on peut se
rejoindre sur ce qu'ils représentent
j'ai pas 75% ou 95% du problème la
question animale
si on regarde en france un france est un
pays d'élevage intensif 95% des cochons
aujourd'hui sont élevés dans des
élevages sans aucun accès à l'extérieur
sur des caillebotis
c'est à dire des dalles en béton avec
des sons à jour et pour laisser passer
la merde et les truies sont installe
presque la moitié de leur vie elles sont
inséminées artificiellement les
porcelets sont castrés on leur coupe
lors que on leur livre les dents et pour
les poulets on a fait des recherches
génétiques
aujourd'hui les poulets on a une
croissance qui est deux fois plus rapide
qu'il ya quelques années donc ils
peuvent fusion du mal à se déplacer ils
ont des problèmes de boiterie sont les
problèmes de da site de deux crises
cardiaques de problèmes de dos dans les
poumons et on pourrait faire comme ça
99% des lapins sont arrivés sourde et en
des cages sûr qu'un sol grillagé 70% des
poules pondeuses sont dans des cages
aussi avec leur espace de vie sur une
feuille a4 on leur coupe une partie du
bec pour éviter qu'elle le cannibalisme
on utilise des hormones pour
synchroniser les chaleurs par exemple et
chèvre quand une image peut-être la plus
cool on va dire en france aujourd'hui la
plupart des élevages de chèvres ne font
plus de pâturages l'extérieur les
chèvres c'est un cheptel de chèvres par
élevage qui sont elles aussi
synchroniser inséminer artificiellement
on va leur poser des éponges dans le
vagin avec une espèce de diffusion
d'hormones pour synchroniser les
chaleurs on a de supers rationaliser
tout ça c'est poser les animaux ce sont
des objets en fait
le fait qu'elles sont la sentience quels
qu'ils soient des animaux qui vivent qui
est des désirs et des émotions c'est des
contraintes pour les éleveurs
aujourd'hui mais l'élevage chez ca et du
coup toute cette longue digression pour
dire qu'il ya un certain nombre de gens
dans cette société avec lesquels on peut
obtenir des avancées significatives pour
les animaux et qui sont pas d'accord
avec l'idée d'abolition hugo desnoyer
par exemple et contre 75% à ce qui se
fait aujourd'hui en france
et si aujourd'hui on peut obtenir des
choses et s'allier en toute intelligence
pour interdire une pratique
allons-y
si on arrive à avoir des conditions
d'élevage propres on n'a pas des lapins
dans des feuilles a4 qui sont avec la
tête qui basculent sur le côté j'ai
appris grâce à vous le syndrome
vestibulaire qui crée des désordres de
synchronisation des mouvements et
d'équilibré chez le lapin et c'est très
impressionnant et ça doit être très
débilitants à supporter tous les jours
si on si on revit dias a imaginé vous et
d'élevage digne de ce nom et qu'on fasse
une mise à bord proprement c'est à dire
que la bête ne se voit pas partir et ne
sens ne sentent ici pas dans une
situation de stress elle n'a pas le
temps de sentir l'adrénaline le stress
qui a dans un abattoir est ce que ça
vous pose problème de manger ce type de
viande la cie la viande a été élevé
propres mots s'il ya une est-ce que vous
avez vu le film de tom hooper grandin
tempel groening
est ce que vous comprenez la question
mais bien sûr je comprends ci a fait la
question je pense que l'animal c'est à
dire qu'est ce que le moment on
transforme l'animal en viande
quand on lui retire la vie 6 7 6 ce
moment là et en douceur
ouais alors il ya plein de choses
intéressantes par rapport à ça c'est que
déjà je pense qu'on peut dissocier de
problème éthique pour faciliter la chose
là problème de la souffrance
la problème de la mise le problème de la
mise à mort le problème de la souffrance
un pour moi il est là aujourd'hui dans
représentatif de ce qui se passe dans
l'élevage c'est une vraie
indéniable qui est indéniable qui est
difficile au niveau des niveaux de
consommation qu'on a aujourd'hui on a
plus d'un milliard d'animaux qui sont
tués dans un abattoir en france donc
c'est décadence qui sont énormes
c'est difficile en laissant la
consommation au niveau où elles sont
aujourd'hui en france on est un des pays
où on consomme le plus de produits
animaux au monde produits animaux au
monde donc c'est difficile d'imaginer
même alors là pour le coup on est dans
une taupe y met plus plus imaginer nos
frères des superbes bonnes conditions
aux animaux donc à la question la
souffrance qui est liée aux conditions
d'élevage conditions de transport aux
conditions d'abattage aux mutilations et
c est la question de la mise à mort la
question de la mise à mort pour moi elle
se pose de la même façon si on est
antispécistes c'est à dire qu'on
considère que le fait d'appartenir à une
autre espèce que l'espèce humaine n'est
pas un critère en soi qu'il faut aller
en chercher d'autres parce que sinon
c'est les mêmes mécaniques ont avec le
racisme le sexisme au moins pas encore
prouvé le fait que le simple fait
d'appartenir à une autre espèce est en
soi un critère à prendre objectivement
c'est il faut qu'on dise le fait
d'appartenir à une autre espèce à une
implication en termes de chez pas
d'intelligence de ressentir des élus de
conscience d'émotion alors là ok ça ne
parlera mais le fait d'appartenir à une
autre espèce en soi n'est pas un critère
c'est la position de lentilles spécisme
qui est la nôtre
là notre sens l'argent des philosophes
aujourd'hui qu'il ait un vrai débat de
société
donc à partir de ce moment là la
question de la mort se pose là même la
même façon avec les êtres humains c'est
à dire que si on est d'accord qui et
c'est ok de tuer un être humain sans
souffrance c'est à dire je suis pas
prend un orphelin car aucun des
orphelins un vieux maintenant on prend
un orphelin qui a aucune qui a qui a pas
de gens qui se sont attachés à lui par
exemple qui est tout seul dans la forêt
comme il ya eu des enfants sauvages
tu sais les enfants sauvages qui ont été
retrouvés à deux enfants qui sont
retrouvés du coup totalement livrés à
eux mêmes quand survécu dans la forêt où
tu veux ou tu vois là qui s'est passé
pour enlever les critères souffrance
c'est à dire que 6 et 1 7 enfant là tu
vas me dire où lui prive de ce qu'il ya
de plus principal pour lui c'est à dire
l'âge
sa capacité à interagir alors si
quelqu'un trouve qu'il n'ya pas de
problème avec ça et défend l'idée qu'il
ya pas de problème avec tuer les animaux
alors je trouve qu'il est cohérent dans
son positionnement éthique et là je peux
tuer les enfants orphelins
c'est sa maison d un fort ce débat et la
question pour moi
non parce qu'il ya d'autres critères
mais c'est à dire que la la enfin il ya
d'autres critères
oui et non enfin je pense que cette
question pour moi elle est ouverte la
question de mois si on tue la cie un
sniper qui me tue et que je meure d'un
coup à part le fait que ça va peut-être
créer la souffrance auprès des gens qui
pensent comme absolu qui peuvent
apprécier
je sais pas si c'est après c'est le cas
pour quelques personnes peut-être donc
elles vont souffrir donc il ya le
problème éthique il revient sur la
souffrance mais la question que moi du
jour au lendemain la que je ne vois même
pas ma mort je n'anticipe pas et que
j'ai du mal à considérer où il est le
problème c'est beaucoup plus clair avec
la souffrance que la question de
interrompre une vie d'un coup il ya des
gens des philosophes qui considère que
le fait d'avoir une vie biographique de
voir des projets et que le fait d'
interrompre la vie d'un individu est un
problème éthique pour moi c'est une
vraie question qui est super forte et
que j'ai du mal moi même enfin j'ai du
mal pour moi même dans ma réflexion de
propre à trancher non mais c'est juste
que je crois pas que c'était la
situation que tu décris soit possible
parce que même quand on parle de
l'abattage à la ferme par exemple ou
dans des bonnes conditions on évite la
question du transport que en offre aux
animaux des conditions très bonne
d'accès aux pâturages de soins etc
il se trouve que on est en train de nier
que les uns et que les animaux --dont
des relations entre eux c'est à dire
quand on va tuer à la carabine
un bovin c'est ce qu'elle c'est le cas
dans l'abattage à la ferme et
quelques-uns qui quelques éleveurs qui
défendent cette idée qui sont pas très à
l'aise avec l'idée d'élever parce que
quand on commence à avoir des relations
affectives avec un animal on a de moins
en moins c'est moins en moins facile à
l'ulb beaucoup voilà mais au-delà de
tout ça il ya d'autres
ce bovin qu'on a tué au fusil cas
peut-être pas vu venir la mort il avait
des relations avec d'autres bovins et a
les mêmes les relations sont super forte
entre les bovins il y en a qui s'aiment
qui se détestent de toujours vu le corps
via l'a3 écuries comme llodra qui boxe
il ya toujours son copain d'à côté qu il
appelle toute la journée mais on
connaissait les anecdotes avec un chien
qui peut rester pendant des jours devant
la tombe de l'humain avec lesquels il
s'était elle avait pris d'affection
on voit les relations entre les maires
entre les mères et les enfants sur une
vache laitière et vous poser ces
questions à des éleveurs ils savent très
bien que pour produire du lait pour
faire du fromage
il faut qu'on fasse naître des veaux
donc maintenir une lactation et les
veaux sont séparés généralement au bout
de 24 heures et on sait très bien que
quand ça se passe dans les étables balle
à la mère elle va meubler pendant
plusieurs jours et le veau son côté
aussi donc je vous dirai pas besoin de
parler pour comprendre qu'il ya un
attachement qui a été brisée à ce moment
là donc question d'internet je suis
désolé de contenu je voulais tu veux
terminer quasi question l'internet
l'exploitation du travail animal et tel
antinomiques du bien-être animal aux
interrogations n'est-il pas possible
d'avoir des exploitations éthique type
ch votre chien aveugle sous l'équitation
c'est sûrement si sûrement je pense que
il ya plus il ya plusieurs il ya des
personnes dans le milieu animal isme
c'est un tout petit milieu
donc c'est un peu comme en dix combats
de mouches dans une éprouvette qui
disent que le fait d'avoir des chiens
pour par exemple aider les personnes
aveugles à guider les personnes aveugles
chose comme ça c'est une chose qu'il
faudrait pas faire enfin qu'ils sont qui
milite pour une rupture entre les
humains et les autres animaux sans
penser qu'on peut avoir une relation
sympa avec un autre animal qu'ils soient
pas justement l'exploitation qui soit je
pense que sauber il suffit de regarder
les animaux pour comprendre que le chien
peut être super content de faire de
l'exercice
je ne sais quoi mais motion waimes après
il faut il ya tout un bouquin qui
s'appelle zoos police qui sait une
prospection ça va tout ça c'est si on
est sincère avec la considération qu'on
a pour les animaux là on peut imaginer
de regarder leur attitude leur
comportement et le fait qu'il fasse une
activité soit pas sur quelque chose
qu'ils aiment ou qu'ils n'aiment pas
après je suis pas sûr que ce soit le cas
avec je veux pas généraliser je suis pas
sûr le cas avec des animaux des chevaux
de trait quoi quand je prise bosser ça
dépend ça dépend jusqu'où relais bien ou
ce jusque on les pousse et comment mener
la question le bios de daf ou ses
aspects non mais franchement je peux je
pense qu'il ya des situations sans avoir
de façon honnête mais dans une société
on utilise les animaux je peux
comprendre aussi les gens qui ont tant
qu'ils arrivaient recettes
cette position là parce qu'on est dans
une société qui est tellement j'aime pas
ce mot extrême mais dans une société qui
est tellement pas honnête dans le débat
et dans l'utilisation des animaux que
oui de dire maintenant mes animaux sont
bien je viens les éleveurs dit ça je
veux dire les éleveurs il
un moment donné je filmais dans une
salle de gavage au d'année en année une
salle de gavage où les canards allait
être gavé donc soumis pendant deux
semaines dans des cages individuelles à
l'époque où je filmais ses cages là sont
interdites aujourd'hui depuis 2011 2016
15 jeu mélangeant les dates bref au
moment où je faisais cette enquête ils
étaient garés dans des cages
individuelles
l'éleveur savais que j'allais filmée
parce qu'il m'avait donné une
autorisation de le faire et il m'a dit à
un moment donné vous allez voir les
canaris vient de se faire graver tout
seul résultat un moment où là il
commence à gaver il chope les canards
par la main il en retire le coup et
leurs enfants sans but qu il passe à
l'autre et puis la seconde approche les
canards fut dans la cage
c'est là je me suis dit mais comment il
a pu me dire ça alors qu'ils savaient
qu'ils m'avaient donné une autorisation
de filmer et que j'allais le film et que
j'allais voir ce qui se passe et je
pense que il se passe il ya un mécanisme
qu'on attendrait de dissonance cognitive
de choses qui se passent on transforme
la réalité et on la voit plus comme elle
est on a envie de voir les animaux comme
étant heureux dans son élevage alors
qu'ils sont privés d'un accès au plein
air et je pense que ça peut être sincère
amont ont donné une pas de farce
forcément tout le temps et on s'habitue
à ces conditions-là psychologique de
défense c'est comme ça que vous lui
exactement
autre question de tergnier d'internet
que ferais tu ont des vaches si on est
mauvais plus il y en aurait peut-être
moins c'est possible parce que l'élevage
la question c'est pas de libérer les
animaux c'est de couper le robinet c'est
à dire qu'on fait naître les animaux
avec l'infini elle au final le fait de
les tuer et donc sûrement qu'il ya
certains au delà des vaches je prends la
question générale est par exemple il ya
des poulets aujourd'hui qui sont dans
les élevages et qu'ils sont
qui peuvent pas vivre décemment au
niveau adulte parce qu'on les a fait une
sélection génétique qui font qu'ils ont
plein de maladies qui peuvent pas se
tenir sur leurs pattes et tout ça donc
il ya un certain nombre d'animaux si on
arrêtait de les manger qui n'est prévue
aujourd'hui qui serait pas là et puis
après c'est tout une question de de la
société con
veut pour demain est ce qu'on est
capable d'imaginer une société on a des
relations pacifiées avec les os des
autres animaux ok il ya des animaux qui
existent qu'on mange pas les chats les
chiens on les mange pas il existe aux
jambes aux eyzies il ya des animaux
liminaire oui mais je veux dire qu'ils
existent dans notre société aujourd'hui
qu'on mange pas il ya pas mal de il ya
aussi des animaux enfin qu'on appelle
liminaire dans la ville des pigeons
l'air et tout ça qui existent alors
quand on les mange pas aujourd'hui en
général j'ai dans une crise économique
arrive on commence à sa cession et
pourquoi ou de 18,6 escargots france un
ca d origine la famille et après on va
garder l'habitude je vais quand ça
n'explique autre question d'internet la
loi des fonds tels des animaux pour
interrogation en france c'est légal de
manger du chien ou du chat pour nos
interrogations
en france il ya plusieurs statues pour
les aliments les animaux de compagnie
des animaux de rente donc on peut pas
faire la même chose avec les animaux de
compagnie que les animaux de rente les
chiens de chasse ont classé dans animaux
de compagnie donc on peut pas
les emmener dans un abattoir voilà ce
qu'est ce qui est totalement
contradictoire c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on fait à la chaîne
dans un abattoir
on peut pas le faire sur un chien on
serait puni pour cruauté puis par la
prison a c'est un délit voilà donc ce
qu'on fait à la chaîne s'est autorisé
mais ce qu'on pourrait faire sur un seul
individu dans l'espace public sera
encore pire on aurait une réaction très
vive des gens c'est une société
totalement schizophrène et pas du tout
cohérent dans ses relations avec les
animaux et la loi aujourd'hui non elle
garantit pas aucune protection enfin une
protection tout à fait minimale
généralement la loi elle encadre plus
tôt les activités aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que il ya eu par exemple je parle
des animaux d'élevage sur les y avait
pas de réglementation sur l'élevage des
poulets il y en a eu une qui sait à
commencer à s'appliquer en 2007
et quand il ya eu des pourparlers au
niveau de la commission européenne pour
discuter des normes au niveau du nombre
de poulets par mètre carré par exemple
eh ben les si la science elle disait
qu'au delà de 25 kg par mètre carré
parce que c'est comme ça qu'on parle
donc ça veut dire à peu près 2 kg par
par poulet donc 12 tous foulé par mètre
carré on va dire qu'on se dise pour lé
père mètres carrés c'était impossible de
garantir des conditions de bien-être des
animaux
même avec des bonnes conditions de
d'aération voilà c'était impossible
donc on a hésité à sourcer 25 kg par
mètre carré et la réglementation elle
est montée aux 42 kg par mètre carré
aujourd'hui l'alimentation elle autorise
42 kg par mètre carré c'est à dire 20 à
21 pour les voir on peut monter à 28,9
pour les prix des exports qui font pas
tout à fait de kilos et donc on
s'aperçoit que la réglementation elle
est plus là pour offrir un discours aux
filières pour dire il ya une
réglementation sur les abattoirs on doit
pas stresser les animaux inutilement par
exemple ne pas faire souffrir les
animaux donc c'est plus pour alimenter
un discours mais dans la réalité
toujours droit de la pin up électrique
pour le faire avancer dans le petit
couloir un adroit sur les faits sur des
animaux
sur les parties arrières des animaux et
sur les animaux adultes mais si c'est
fait ce que sur vos vidéos on voit quand
même des gammes et des grands parce que
la réglementation n'est pas respectée
déjà au bâton tous les abattoirs son
monitoring qu'ils ont filmée de a à z
non non c'est un projet sur la loi
falorni c'est à dire qu on a diffusé
beaucoup d' enquête sur les abattoirs en
2015 2016
ça a eu un ca provoqué un choc au niveau
l'union pull et l'opinion publique
ça a provoqué la mise en place d'une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire et
qui a été un travail qui a été vraiment
super de qualité avec des des
convocations de gens qu'on n'entendait
jamais parlé comme jean paul bigard par
exemple si on peut y revenir après et il
ya eu donc olivier falorni et le
rapporteur qui ont fait un espèce de
deux rapports suite à ça et 60 mesures
pour améliorer la condition des animaux
de boucherie dans les abattoirs
suite à ça il ya une loi qui a été à
chaque fois il ya eu un dégraissage quoi
chaque fois qu'on passe d'une étape à la
suivante eu un dégraissage et il ya une
loi qui a été évoqué en premier voté en
première lecture à l'assemblée nationale
qui a effectivement adopté l'idée de
mettre des caméras dans les abattoirs
mais il faut que ça passe encore au
sénat et que ça passe en deuxième
lecture à l'assemblée nationale
entre les deux il ya eu les élections
céline sénatoriale qui ont bouleversé le
planning au niveau du sénat et pour le
moindre que la loi allait bloquer entre
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
effectivement à partir du 1er janvier
2018 mais du coup cette loi est repoussé
il devient voire une obligation
d'installer des caméras dans l'incertain
certains postes de l'abattoir c'était
pas pour fliquer les employés aux
vestiaires mais à l'endroit où ont
étourdi on tue les animaux qui doivent
être contrôlés par les services
vétérinaires molle en bottes noires
vidéo c'est ça ouais c'est ça mais avec
un gros problème qui est que ces images
ne pourraient être vus que par les
services vétérinaires qui sont déjà
présents dans les abattoirs et qu'ils
font mon pain qui font pas leur boulot
qui sent qu'il ya des grosses carences
qui se sait pas que mon discours à moi
ou les assauts c'est aussi des
inspecteurs de la commission européenne
il ya des inspecteurs qui vient de voir
si les les états font leur boulot qui
ont déjà tapé sur les doigts et sur les
carences qui ont insisté sur les
carences des services vétérinaires
français et pour revenir à cette
question de la commission d' enquête sur
les abattoirs il ya jean paul bigard qui
a été interviewé convoqué et qui doit
répondre aux questions des députés et
qui est quelqu'un donc qui est président
d'un espèce de société qui a presque qui
habituent je crois presque la moitié des
vaches de réforme laitière en france
sera au tour des parents elles forment
le tiercé les vaches qui sont en fin de
carrière les vaches laitières qu'on
exploite pour leur survie de ce salon
ouais c'est ça c'est à dire que les
vaches laitières aujourd'hui on leur
fait faire des veaux entreprend le lait
et à la fin on les emmène à l'abattoir
et 40% la viande bovine la viande de
boeuf aujourd'hui sonder la viande de
vache de vieilles vaches laitières et
donc la socopa les sept espèces de gld
agglomérat las illas aux copains
bigard et charal qui sont une même
société aujourd'hui qui sont rachetés se
rachètent les uns les autres
donc le jean paul bigard le président de
7 à baisser assez grosses sociétés et il
a très bien dit que pendant l'audition
que il dépenser des sommes colossales
ces ses propres termes pour dans le
budget communication et que autant on
pouvait montrer une ou deux secondes de
bovins une ou deux secondes de bovins
dans les prés mais après il fallait
passer directement à l'avion n'est
absolument pas parler de ce qui se
passait dans les abattoirs de la
question de la mise à mort des animaux
qui aujourd'hui un un sujet qui est qui
est évidemment pose problème et qui est
un peu le neuhof est un levier très
important pour parler de la question
animale parce que on est très mal très
mal à l'aise aujourd'hui dans notre
consommation de produits animaux de
parler des abattoirs de voir la mort des
animaux le sang qui coule donc c'est un
espèce d'angle mort quoi qu'est ce que
j'irais d'accord c'est dans vos vidéos
la voir la peur dans l'oeil d'une vache
bon je monte à cheval depuis des
décennies et je pratique une équitation
qui est dit
équitation éthologique l'homme qui
murmurait à l'oreille des chevaux
s'imprégner lot de la communication de
l'ong pour pouvoir faire interagir
maximiser la performance sportif grâce
en enlevant le stress quand on voit la
peur sur vos vidéos
cc c'est paralysant vous vous votre la
pire la pire chose que vous ayez pu voir
ou qui vous et qui vous a le plus marqué
durant cette petite expédition commando
pour extraire et soustrait à exfiltrer
des images c'est quoi c'est la pire des
expériences que vous avez pu
voir ressentir c'est tout à fait
subjectif parce que ses extérieurs on
sait pas ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
des têtes d animaux mais des choses les
plus difficiles
dur comment dire bouleversante c&c les
cochons les cochons qui sont gazés ou
co2 il ya un certain nombre d'abattoirs
je cite des noms l'abattoir de carmine
et l'abattoir de leclerc c'est à dire
toute la charcutaille qui est vendu chez
leclerc provient de cochon qui sont
gazés au ce2 galles
c'est une technique qui aujourd'hui
légale au niveau de la réglementation
mais qui dans les attendus les
réglementations que ses débuts dès avant
les articles et les attendus avec
pourquoi on a fait cette loi et puis
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait améliorer la
question du gazage des cochons est
quelque chose qui qui existent donc on a
mis dans la réglementation mais
clairement quelque chose qu'il faudrait
interdire trouver une alternative
donc on utilise le report suffocation
c'est ça on rentre les cochons dans une
nacelle on les descend dans un puits un
puits de co2 comme le co2 est plus lourd
que l'air au fond il arrive à des taux
de concentration de co2 qui font que
l'oxygène
il ya plus d'oxygène dans l'organisme
donc c'est exactement le même mécanisme
que de se noyer suffoquer et sauf qu'ils
descendent pas d'un coup dans cette
fausse que le gaz est un ver cif ça
brûle et donc on a réussi à avoir des
images d'une caméra installée avec dans
la nacelle qui descend avec les cochons
et des cochons qui ça on revient à cette
histoire de mes cochons dans la cour de
la ferme de mes grands parents mais les
cochons qui
qui hurlent qui se jettent à droite à
gauche dans la nacelle d'ailleurs c'est
un de ces cochons là qui a fait tomber
une caméra et qui nous a fait repérer
dans un échappatoire justement à tel
point que tel point ils sont paniqués
c'est quelque chose qui est qui est
vraiment très très dérangeant parce que
vous avez des animaux comme les moutons
par exemple sont des animaux de proies
comme vous dites et qui quand ils sont
dans des situations de peur de stress ne
font plus de vocalises se sont tétanisés
bouge plus enfin hills où ils réagissent
très très fort quand ils sont séparés
des autres
une fois qu'ils sont dans cette position
là ils réagissent plus donc c'est
difficile nous d'imaginer de voir ce qui
se passe le comprendre ce qui se passe
dans leur esprit takata toudic c'est ça
voilà comme les oiseaux sur le dos je
serai jamais un cochon lui il exprime sa
son émotion et les cris d'un cochon qui
gueule dans un abattoir ça c'est très
fort à est d'ailleurs dans les abattoirs
les employés sont des casques antibruit
une cause est décrit des cochons est-ce
que vous avez discuté avec saison pauli
est ce que vous avez discuté avec par
exemple la médecine du travail qui
s'occupe de ses salariés par exemple je
sais pas s'il sous quelle un génie sont
aussi celles à aimer ça aussi quoique ce
soit est-ce que l'airé les gars qui
bosse qui a infligé l'amant qui sont
obligés de la donner pour manger eux
mêmes
est-ce qu'ils ont des troubles
psychologiques est ce qu'ils sont
stressés est-ce que c'est des
populations à risque il ya des
statistiques autour de ça faut voir
x lire le bouquin qui s'appelle steak
machine je le ferai je le guichet qui
justement a ressorti une étude de la msa
on voit alors le premier les premières
maladies c'est les troubles ce que le
taureau musculo squelettiques
donc ça c'est les abattoirs c'est une
des rares industries qui a très peu
évolué en termes technologiques
on a un ancien inspecteur vétérinaire
auquel on montre les images avant les
sortir souvent qui a bossé comme haut
niveau comme vacataire dans les services
vétérinaires et dans les années 90 quand
tu vois les images qu'on sort là
aujourd'hui en 2016 2017 2018 il dit
mais c'est faux quoi c'est exactement
comme comme il ya 20 ans 30 ans dans les
abattoirs
je pense qu'il ya peu il n'y a pas
beaucoup d'industries qui ont pas évolué
donc c'est un boulot qui est super
compliqué ya un autre film qui s'appelle
seigneur seigneur qui est super
intéressant aussi qu'ils voient sur les
relations qui lient à l'intérieur des
abattoirs entre la hiérarchie et les
employés d'abattoirs qui est souvent une
une
relation de souvent de mépris par
rapport aux femmes c'est un espace qui
est très hiérarchisé et il ya un lanceur
d'abattoirs qu'il raconte ça beaucoup
très bien c'est mauricio garcia pereira
qui n ose le lanceur d'alerté qui est un
gars qui a travaillé pendant sept ans un
abattoir à limoges qui a six films et
notamment les vaches les vaches
gestantes ou en fin de gestation qui
arrive à l'abattoir de limoges qui
filmait des foetus de vaud des veaux
prêt à naître dans une boyauderie et qui
raconte justement le fait qu'il ait pété
les plombs dans l'abattoir à un moment
donné il raconte ça ils se retrouvent
tout autant dans une situation de
conflit et se voit en train de prendre
un couteau et de menacer son chef
d'equipe avec son couteau et
heureusement il ya des collègues qui
l'ont arrêté
ils ont dit les y rentre chez toi il est
rentré chez lui s'est écroulé en pleurs
il s'est dit mais j'ai fait j'ai failli
tuer quelqu'un quoi il a réalisé son
acte mais comme on est dans un
environnement qui est la violence peut
être banalisé les gens ont des couteaux
des armes et le boulot est dur il ya du
mépris c'est un travail à la chaîne
faut savoir que le travail allait chaîne
était inventée par les abattoirs de
chicago que ford c s'est inspiré des
abattoirs chicago pour faire le travail
à la chaîne que aux états unis c'est un
un article qui disait que les employés
mettez des couches parce qu'il n'avait
pas à la pause donc c'est un boulot qui
est qui minent les gens et pour moi
avoir passé trois semaines dans un
abattoir pour y avoir travaillé on voit
très bien que vous avez d'abord d'aider
au doux nom j'étais sur un poste
d'aspiration des moines le plein de il
ya très peu de gens qui font la mise à
mort un abattoir
c'est la plupart des gens sont sur une
petite tâche sur la vieille et son pib
au ces des ouvriers qui sont plus ou
moins qualifiés donc ça va du smic au s2
fin qui sont qui peuvent être à 2000
euros
quel type de formation ça va de rien on
fait le couteau n'importe qui on lui
explique qu autour d'un petit imminente
il ya plein couteau non ça va être
plutôt des gens qui ont un bep hookaew
voilà des choses comme ça mais plein il
ya plein d'autres postes dans les
abattoirs
il ya peu de gens qui sont au contact
des animaux vivants il ya le bouvier par
exemple où les gens qui sont
l'accrochage des volailles juste comme
ça et puis les gens qui tuent mais c'est
c'est ça va être les gens qui tu vas
voir la personne qui étourdit la
personne qui tue ça va être trois à
quatre personnes dans l'abattoir tous
les autres après sont sous les déc ou
primaire sur les habillages il ya plein
de postes qui sont qui sont qu'ils sont
c'est quelque chose qui est très
découpées ce qu'il ya peu de gens qui
sont responsables de la mort des animaux
bout du compte est que c'est celui qui a
qui a donné le coup de matador est ce
que c'est lui qui a donné le coup de
couteau alors que l'animal était déjà
étourdi ces mécanismes classiques de
déresponsabilisation
c'est ça et puis je pense qu'il ya une
habitude aussi qui fait que l'être
humain c'est une pâte à modeler je vais
on a vu des exemples dans l'histoire ça
on s'en aller plus loin mais on montre
qu'on est capable de tout et du pire et
le meilleur
on va parler de la chasse si tu veux
[Rires]
c'est quoi ton avis sur la chasse alors
je te parle pas de la chaîne des
touristes un peu ce dos pour joueurs qui
montent à cheval et qui court pour des
heures derrière parce que je veux dire
un chasseur alors je j'enlève ma
casquette l214 parce que c'est possible
ouais non mais je préfère le dire ce que
c'est pas une position de l'association
là sur la chasse parce qu'on n'est pas
on travaille pas ses sujets sains de sa
pose des questions que là je me permet
d'aborder dans le cadre de think a
review parce que je trouve ça un moment
où on peut parler on peut avoir expliqué
les choses en plus en profondeur et tout
ça ça soulève la question de la
prédation
c'est que à partir du moment où on
imagine le mans on voit le monde on voit
les êtres humains comme des animaux
parmi les autres qui ont des capacités
en espèces d'intelligence collective qui
est qu'aucune espèce a atteint
aujourd'hui c'est
on peut pas contester c'est
incontestable qui a une capacité à
résoudre des problèmes qui au delà de
toute autre espèce en général l'espèce
humaine que c'est pas le gardois voir
des êtres humains qui sont déficients et
tout ça mais c'est pas pour ça qu'on les
mange mais si on considère donc le monde
avec des êtres des cons et des animaux
parmi les autres
la question de la chasse c'est la
prédation comme une autre et ça soulève
une question qui que par simple cahiers
antispécistes ont discuté sans que c'est
une revue qui est super intéressant qui
va au fond des choses qu'ils voient pas
forcément les choses fin qui va oser
questionner les problèmes de la
prédation la question du naturalisme une
question très très important dans une
société qu'on n'entend pas beaucoup qui
est de dire que tout ce qui se passe
dans la nature c'est bien ce qui se
passe dans la nature c'est à défendre il
ya une espèce de symbiose des animaux il
faut les remettre à leur état naturel et
on voit pas que la prédation que ce qui
se passe
même si on enlevait les options dans les
laits on enlève les êtres humains ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui dans autant le
mécanisme d'interdépendance des animaux
avec les autres c'est un truc abominable
c'est à dire que des hyènes peuvent
maintenir en vie leur proie
pendant des jours elles vont les blessés
et les maintenir en vie il est consommé
petit à petit enfin les potes frigo les
poèmes et les pires atrocités sont
existe déjà à l'état naturel et être
humain n'a pas inventé la cruauté de la
chasse c'est cruel non mais je veux dire
le fait le fait que le point de vue ça
dépend le point de vue on a le point de
vue de l'animal qui doit tuer pour
nourrir pour vivre pour continuer à
vivre
le point de vue de l'animal qui est
course et qui en panique totale
j'ai pas si vous imaginez vous sortez
dans la rue aujourd'hui non un être
humain et on a un insécurité totale il
ya des gens qui peuvent course est pour
nous bouffer je veux dire quelles que
soient leurs raisons qu'elle soit
légitime parce que il crève
si nos courses pas pour de bouffer mais
imaginez dans quel état vous vivriez
vous-même c'était terrible c'était la
question des animaux la question de
l'eia que et migros est poursuivi par la
paf c'est à peu près pareil donc c'est
ça peut s'apparenter à ça ça peut ça
rentre pas s'apparenter à ça ça va c'est
pas la finalité est pas la même quoique
qu'il ya les balles mais enfin il ya
d'autres choses mais effectivement quand
on est dans un canoë quand on meurt noyé
mais en tout cas cette situation-là de
la prédation et c'est une vraie question
à venir peut-être dansante en 150 ans
c'est une question qu'on pourra creuser
sincèrement tout est ce que tu respectes
les chasseurs bah du coup là le vrai
chasseur pas la boucherie organisé le
week-end avec des associations de chasse
qu'il faut un petit peu ce qu'ils
veulent n'importe où je parle d'un gars
qui va chasser mettre à mort
correctement sa bête
la piste et se planquer de panat stressé
plein pour là c'est le respect celle de
sa proie en rejoint les mêmes les mêmes
questions ont rejoint la même question
que les mêmes réponses que j'ai fait
tout à l'heure sur le fait de l'élevage
sans souffrance c'est à dire que
l'animal chassé
c'est peut-être une mère un père c'est
peut-être un frère une soeur d'un autre
animal qui était à côté
tu peut jamais garantir que l'animal tu
vas y tu es correctement enfin et après
il ya plein de choses aujourd'hui
chasseurs tu n'as pas de chasseurs
humain aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
nécessité alimentaire à le faire et à
partir de là je trouve que ça serait ça
serait bien qu'ils rangent son arbalète
sans marquer ces fusils voilà mais je
trouve que ça ne sent pas du tout visé
je pense que c'est c'est à peu près la
même c'est c'est la même chose que
qu'est la question de pas tout à fait la
même chose que la question la prédation
parce que ce n'est pas une question de
nécessité
on voit plein droit de chasser à
l'arbalète en france à la wii à l'arc
marcoule et voilà pour moi c'est ça ça
pose ça pose des problèmes éthiques
clair ouais c'est clair après si c'est
peu j'aime pas trop la question de
respect pas de respect c'est la question
est ce que est ce que c'est quelque
chose qui devrait être remise en cause
questionné que je trouve pas juste pour
l'animal qui est tué ouais je trouve que
c'est pas super fan ou de question
d'internet qui est en train d'arriver
le petit clavier d'entre eux public moi
je le prendrais du dessus fini vos
propos je te promets ok alors aussi ses
succès c'est très bien cela on peut être
végétalien son propre de couple aimant
point d'interrogation on a besoin de
protéines animales point d'interrogation
question d'internet donc les compléments
way peut-être que tu prends des
compléments way quels types de
compléments vergano a fait valoir
j'explique dans quel les termes vite
fait végétarien c'est en mange pas de
chair animale végétalien on mange pas de
produits animaux donc c'est aussi
ce passé dont se nourrit que de végétaux
donc on y en a qui parlent vegan c'est à
peu près comme végétalien sauf que l'on
rajoute deux dans l'est la question
vestimentaire par exemple ou des
produits testés cosmétiques tout ça donc
moi j'essaye d'être à peu près vegan sur
moi n'empêche que voilà ce que c'est sûr
bien ce que je disais tout au début il
ya plein de choses qu'on vienne me
reprocher mais bon c'est pas on essaie
de faire au mieux comme on peut et
la question des protéines oui on a
besoin de protéines pour nourrir ses la
construction ont dégusté machin de ça
c'est vital les protéines si les acides
aminés essentiels et on peut les trouver
dans les végétaux très facilement donc
youpi c'est génial parce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle et il ya aucun problème
avec les protéines on est dans un dans
les pays occidentaux aujourd'hui là pour
les gens qui écoutent derrière un
ordinateur ils ont un mode de vie qui
est qui leur permet de bien manger et
consomme généralement on consomme
généralement trop de protéines animales
de protéines en général donc si on mange
normalement l'apport calorique normal on
a assez de protéines dans notre
consommation aujourd'hui il ya un
problème un problème une vitamine à
laquelle il faut faire très attention
c'est la vitamine b12
cette vitamine b12 on la retrouve
essentiellement dans les produits
animaux
donc quand on est végétalien où reagan
il faut avoir un apport extérieur de
vitamine b12 c'est ce que je prends moi
dans la vie guan qui est un complément
alimentaire db 12,7 b12 allait donner
quand on regarde l'industrie de la bd
vitamine b12 c'est pas les végétaliens
qui font tourner l'industrie la vitamine
b12 c les animaux d'élevage c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans les animaux
d'élevage sont extrêmement complémenter
c'est à dire que quelqu'un qui me dit
bochy voilà c'est ça à quelqu'un qui me
dit aujourd'hui mais c'est pas naturel
ton truc moi je mange des produits
animaux ça c'est naturel j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir de compléments alimentaires
ils se rendent pas compte qu'ils beauf
qui bouffe une tonnes de compléments
alimentaires
sauf que c'est via les animaux et que
les animaux c'est des emballages qui
fuit en plus donc il faut donner plus
que ce qu'on en aura à la fin et que
l'industrie la b to c avant
d'éventuelles d'abord pour l'industrie
alimentaire mais plein du plein de
compléments alimentaires sont d'abord
pour les animaux d'élevage y compris des
anti anti quotidien parce que là on a
fait des enquêtes dans les élevages de
poulets doux moi j'aime bien dire les
noms des marques donc on a fait des
enquêtes dans les élevages doubs et dans
les fiches d'alimentation qu'on donne
aux poulets il ya du sarrasin qui est un
antioxydant d'antibiotiques qui est
donné constamment aux animaux quoi et la
liste de suppléments alimentaires et les
langues longue comme le bras
et puis par exemple cette question de
compléments alimentaires c'est une
question délicate en france qu'il est
moins présent que des états unis où on a
moins de problèmes avec cette question
des compléments alimentaires mais faut
savoir par exemple le sel est
aujourd'hui enrichi en iode parce qu'on
a vu que la population était carencée en
iode et que c'était un problème donc on
a décidé d'enrichir llyod ans le faire
en iode donc on prend des compléments
alimentaires diodes ans avec le faire
c'est le sel je dis oui tout à fait
autre question d'interdire les produits
bio sont-ils respectueux vis-à-vis des
méthodes d'élevage et d'abattage point
d'interrogation
ouais plus plus que les vaches standard
c'est comme le que ce soit le bio ou de
labels rouges sont des modes d'élevage
qui prennent en considération en général
on pourrait prendre après espèce par
espèce est pas toujours le cas
mais la règle c'est quand même d'offrir
un accès au plein air par exemple aux
animaux donc c'est c'est mieux et ça
fait une sacrée différence avec
l'élevage intensif standard donc si
on veut continuer de consommer de la
viande vaut mieux choisir du label rouge
en france les 10 pas foncez pas un label
qui existe dans beaucoup d'autres pays
ou du joyau permettre aussi sur le web
et non parce que ça dépend dans nos
choix de consommation si je suppose et
entre les blue wave mais si on consume
moins de produits transformés sur les
salades en sachets sont plus chers que
ça dans machin donc donc on se met moins
en plus tout ça après je suis pas en
train de dire que le bio label rouge
c'est oublier youplaboum et à disney
pour les animaux à finir pour les
pourrait que ce soit il ya quand même
son ordination il ya les visages si on
regarde les l'élevage plein air label
rouge bio pour les poules pondeuses par
exemple ben un an un an un an et demi
après leur naissance sont envoyés à
l'abattoir parce que les pics de ponte
descendent même en élevage bio c'est
plusieurs milliers d'animaux toute façon
qu'ils sont concentrés dans les même
élevage une qu'ils ont accès l'extérieur
c'est une conspiration super forte à
l'intérieur
donc c'est si on veut aller au bout des
choses être cohérent dans sa démarche
qu'on est soucieux du bien-être animal
on arrête de les manger
mais si on
n'est pas prêt à le faire si on veut
mettre un petit hic dans son assiette
alors oui ça fait une différence je
passe d'ailleurs le bonjour à d'autres
éleveurs qui s'appelle le boeuf d'herbe
je sais pas si tu as déjà entendu parler
non c'est collectif d'éleveurs qui a
décidé de donner que de l'herbe des
vaches de laisser tranquillement être
sans se faire emmerder il est
complémentaire
autre question d'internet écologiquement
ça représente quoi l'élevage pour
interrogation revient en remuant la
question s'appelle écologiquement ça
représente quoi
l'élevage pendant interrogations et si
on mange de l'avion qui vient d'un
circuit court
est-ce que c'est mieux c'est mieux que
du soja ou des avocats
est ce que la viande de circuit court
est ce que c'est l'ucl du sougey les
avocats ouais alors déjà en propos
liminaire vient de point info qui est un
site avec des sources et plein de
questions sur la question
environnementale de partage ou par kiel
ou davantage de ressources des gages à
effet de serre avec des chiffres source
et tout ça donc ça faut aller voir ce
site si on est vraiment intéressé par la
question environnementale
la question environnementale après à
l'avoir espèce par espèce si on
considère la question par exemple de
gaspillage des ressources
donc c'est un terme énergie et tout ça
enfin c'est toute l'actualité toute la
file
la question finale c'est l'énergie la
question principale
si on regarde au niveau 2 pour preuve
pour produire un kilo de protéines de
viande par exemple
bovine il faut c'est un kilo de
protéines de viande bovine faut sept
kilos de protéines végétales pour les
proches on est les insolites doux si mes
souvenirs sont bons ça dépend le mode
d'élevage ça peut être plus moins ça
dépend si c'est totalement ressort lupa
pour les cochons les poulets on est
plutôt un rapport 5 1 5 kilos de
protéines végétales 1 kg pour obtenir un
kilo de protéines animales donc basse et
protéines végétales il faut les cultiver
il faut mettre des engrais etc
donc si on si on ne veut être
complètement honnête si on regarde par
rapport aux végétaux qui sont
consommables par l'espèce humaine parce
que si c'est de l'herbe manger par des
bovins comme on ne peut pas nous digérer
l'herbe directement de dire que c'est un
ratio de 7 pour 1 c'est pas tout à fait
honnête l'élevage bovin avec le pâturage
sont au niveau mondial s'équilibrent à
peu près on est presque sûr un pour un
mais sur les cochons les poulets on est
plutôt autour de 4,5 kilos quand même de
protéines végétales pour un kilo de
protéines animales
enfin tout expliqué survient de pour
info c'est peut-être un peu rude comme
ça arrive mais sur la question des gaz à
effet de serre c'est à peu près 15 % 14
14,5 pour cent sur l'ensemble de
l'élevage en fait deux tiers des
surfaces agricoles
aujourd'hui niveau mondial sont utilisés
pour l'élevage que ce soit directement
pour par les animaux pour les pâturages
ou pour l'alimentation pour les animaux
deux tiers c'est c'est juste que
gigantesque
je suis pas 55% des tourteaux qui sont
importés en france proviennent du brésil
forêt amazonienne amazonienne machin
tout ça enfin ça match quoi je veux dire
si si on est soucieux de la question
animale du des rapports nord-sud
ces questions là forcément on est poussé
à diminuer de consommation de produits
animaux pas forcément à l'abandonner
si on est juste sur le quai sur ces
questions là si on est si on rajoute la
question de l'éthique animale wave ou
mieux l'abandonner
est-ce que vous avez creusé au niveau 2
association sur l'éducation des masses
ce qu'il n'ya pas hacking social à faire
de ce côté là c'est à dire prendre le
problème en éduquant les gens certes
avec des images chocs pour les avis leur
catatonie sur la souffrance animale mais
est-ce que vous avez envisagé travail
dans les écoles en partenariat avec les
syriens sur les ducs l'éducation alors
il ya un côté un peu condescendant
l'éducation des masses disons qu'on a
tort de 10 peut-être peut-être pas tes
de retarder le titre oui voilà c'est ça
oui paternaliste nous on essaye
d'apporter de l'information c'est c'est
déjà fait et on essaye on se pose à peu
près tous les jours de comment faire
pour que cette information elle touche
le plus grand nombre de gens possible
donc à le mouv masse éducation voilà et
après oui on essaye on va créer un
on a créé un département éducation
donc on va essayer de aussi de
d'apporter la bonne parole auprès des
jeunes parce que il ya que la filière
qui le fait aujourd'hui auprès des
écoles c'est à dire que l'intermède qui
est l'interprofession la viande bovine
intervient dans les écoles
en voit plein de plaquettes aux médecins
enfin noir les médecins sous des
brochures et trucs comme ça donc fait
des animations dans les écoles et tout
ça et donc je crois que la seule à sow
qui a un agrément jour du cll bo pour
faire au niveau environnementalistes
pour faire des interventions dans les
écoles sinon donc il ya un terrain qui
qui est laissée aux mains des filières
qui ont réussi aussi à rendre
obligatoire les produits animaux au sein
des cantines scolaires ça qu'aujourd'hui
une cantine scolaire n'a pas le droit de
lever ou non
elle a obligé de même de nous mettre une
certaine avec un certain rythme de la
viande bovine exactes sur les débouchés
voix basse et de débouchés c'est ça qui
sont énormes
voilà donc ça a été un travail de lobby
des industries de louga léger ou une
question d'internet au monde un monde
veut gagner des millions d'emplois qui
sautent virgules on fait quoi pour
l'interrogation les aides bout avant les
humains pour l'interrogation
en fait ça c'est quand on regarde le
truc par le petit bout de la lorgnette
serre que là haut niveau économique
quand on regarde par exemple l'évolution
au niveau de l'élevage
c'est à dire que je pourrai dans le
xxème siècle avec plus de la moitié de
la population française qui était
travaillé dans l'élevage et aujourd'hui
on est à 3% la population active qui
veut travailler dans l'image et c'est
pas grâce aux vegan à dire que c'est pas
la baisse de la consommation parce que
la consommation de viande n'a cessé
d'augmenter
c'est l'intensification qui a mis des
tonnes de gens au chômage et du coup la
responsabilité elle n'est pas du tout
sur la question d'un monde vegan ou pas
c'est la question de comment en produits
les aliments que l'intensification de la
filière est tous là y'a la viande c'est
une aberration économique quoi total
c'est à dire que comme ce qu'on disait
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure pour la bleue
là la production de protéines il faut
passer par plus tôt par des protéines
végétales
si on regarde les coûts induits par par
la dépollution des plages en bretagne
tout ça c'est à dire qu'on pourrait
largement faire le revenu minimum
universel
quel que soit ce qu'on en pense mais
avec les économies presque la moitié du
budget de l'union européenne passe par
là dans la pac politique et les
subventions mais c'est un truc
incroyable quand la politique agricole
commune
c'est une aberration économique totale
quoi alors si on veut faire l'emploi
pour l'emploi ont fait casser des
cailloux aux gens s'ils vont absolument
va embaucher les gens je pense pas que
c'est comme ça qu'on peut avancer dans
des sociétés on va avoir
l'épanouissement de l'individu s'est pas
l'emploi pour l'emploi embaucher des
gens pour embaucher des gens quoi mais
sinon petit nom pour affaires écosser
les petits pois à la main et du coup ça
fera beaucoup de gens aussi employer les
fèves toutes les légumineuses tout ça ça
fera beaucoup de gens c'est stupide mais
il commence à se faire tard dont je vais
t'envoyer les neuf questions qui les
huit questions qui nous reste d'internet
et tu connais la dernière question qu'on
pose sur cette chaîne qui a baissé à ce
voyage question ses conseils pour les
jeunes générations
alors on est prêt tu choisis ce que tu
veux tu commences pas celle que tu veux
alors si on tue plus jeune ça pollue
moins d'interrogations
c'est quoi la puissance des lobbys du
lait et de la viande en france en europe
en france
l'internation en europe on peut devenir
vegan à partir de quel âge ça j'ai dû
déneiger la pause et faut-il intervenir
dans la nature du coup pour
interrogation aider les animaux torturé
par des gaines point d'interrogation a
raté car là on laisse faire la nature
pour interrogation c'est quoi la limite
point d'interrogation on sait maintenant
que les arbres que vivre entre eux du
coup vous manger quand même les végétaux
par dérogation
on commence par celle là moi si tu veux
la question des végétaux aller seul il
ya un film a dernièrement qui a pas mal
dosé sur la question des arbres on aime
bien mettre un peu de comment dire de
voir quelque chose fins et c'est encore
ce truc de gaia de la nature avec nova
tard d'un truc surnaturel un peu de voix
là après si on découvre que
enfin parce que la communication ça veut
pas dire qu'il ya un sentiment enfin que
je veux dire le fer rouille
il ya une réaction enfin voila si vous
regardez qui est pas de haut niveau les
végétaux non pas de système nerveux
central
il ya plein de choses ont évolué
tivement ou s'il n'y a pas eu vraiment
de justification au fait qu'ils aient
une conscience ou de la souffrance ça
parce que ça a une fonction dans
l'évolution pour les plantes ils n'ont
pas eu forcément besoin seul fait qu'ils
aient pas une mobilité fait que ça il ya
moins de peut-être moins complexes dans
le système nerveux qui soient
développées avec les voilà après même
s'il s'avérait qu'il est une preuve
absolue de la sensibilité des plantes
savard est toujours savourer toujours le
coup de continuer à d'être vegan que
veut pas à cause de ce gaspillage en
passant par les animaux que c'est à dire
que les animaux qu'on mange mange et
végétaux donc en mangeant directement
les végétaux on en mange moins donc on
fera toujours moins de victimes après
les plus motivés seront hara kiri s'ils
ont envie mais moi je n'irai pas jusque
là donc de toutes façons si cette
question est sincère et vaut mieux quand
même manger les végétaux vegan à tout
âge
il ya encore une fois rien notre site
j'ai pas incité sur vegan pratique donc
c'est un c'est un site on a plein de
conseils nutritionnels et on peut
s'inscrire à un bijou challenge pendant
21 jours on reçoit une lettre d'infos et
des conseils c'est gratos on met son
adresse mail et pendant 21 jours si on
veut faire la transition s'essayer au
mécanisme on reçoit une lettre avec des
conseils nutritionnels et il ya la plus
grosse association de diététiciens au
monde qui donne des avis sur tout type
de régime qui est pas du tout partisane
de quoi que ce soit qui dit que le
régime végétalien végétarien strict donc
vegan végétalien et adapté à tous les
âges de la vie pour les femmes enceintes
et les sportifs et tout ce qu'on veut
donc ça c'est tout à fait possible
quoi qu'est ce qu'ils avaient d'autres
lobbys alors le lobby bas par exemple si
on regarde l'iphone et se bat
aujourd'hui qu'est le camp même lobby le
plus puissant en france
ces syndicats agricoles qui soutient
module un modèle tout à fait
productiviste qui soutient à la ferme
des millevaches qu'il soutient tout le
modèle d'élevage qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est grâce à la fnsea quoi c'est leur
truc de co2 aujourd'hui il a changé de
ça a changé de présidence parce que
xavier beulin est décédé qui était le
président à la fois du syndicat et de
grands groupes avril qu un espèce de
gros groupes de qui essaient de dci de
de découler les céréales des grands
céréaliers dans la beauce et tout ça
aujourd'hui c'est christiane lambert qui
est qu une éleveuse de cochon mais ça va
pas changer la philosophie de ce
syndicat la qui lui pour le coup parle à
l'oreille des ministres de l'agriculture
des états généraux l'alimentation qui se
sont terminées et la fnsea étaient là
pour veiller au grain pour que y'a rien
qui qu'aucune mesure qui perturbe le
modèle qui aujourd'hui en place qui est
un modèle sous perf quoi ça contre les
crises alimentaires les crises des
éleveurs de cochons qui arrive
chroniquement ça c'est un modèle qui est
sous perdre des subventions
le pire je mets une parenthèse parce
qu'il est très tard le pire c'est que
ton sujet avec les sujets que nous on
peut étudier un que ce soit la
décroissance le pic énergétique la
surconsommation les guerres des
mouvements géopolitique et tout part de
aller chercher la qualif et d'autres
c'est sainte anne du total bol il faut
que je pense à 4h
parce que c'est un petit mot lee
revenons à nos questions que pensez-vous
des animistes en inde et des extrémistes
il ya un mouvement en inde qui est
instrumentalisée par les nationalistes
en disant que ceux qui mangent de la
viande il faut leur taper dessus
question bombe c'est la question du
rapport de pouvoir quand ce sont des
vegan qui sont au pouvoir qui peuvent
imposer c'est pas des vegan au pouvoir
lassé des nationalistes utilise le
véganisme pour fédérer autour de leurs
proches oui mais que qu'ils le sont
aussi culturellement être ça qui ne
mangent pas de produits animaux et qui
du coup trouve là un point de 1.1
pratique pour essayer de faire la guerre
aux musulmans qui sont plutôt qui vont
au quillio justement le travail dans les
abattoirs et tout ça en inde qui font le
sale boulot généralement là pour ceux
qui continuent à manger
alors si les intouchables qui caris les
cadavres qui ça
et du coup bah c'est pas cessé c'est une
question de pouvoir enfin le pouvoir
amen après il se trouve qu'ils sont qui
consomment pas de produits animaux donc
ils veulent
il va l'imposer sa part la force et du
coup bah c'est bien pour les animaux
mais c'est pas bien dans les relations
sociales que je dise de plus
c'est
c'est les travers de n'importe qui suis
quelqu'un décrété le pouvoir et décrète
demain qu'on mange que que les animaux
se serait tout aussi un problème alors
une autre question at il ajouté il ya
quelques temps certains ont critiqué le
téléthon qui arrive de travailler en
utilisant des expérimentations hannibal
est nécessaire et peut-on vraiment faire
autrement la question de
l'expérimentation animale
c'est une question qui est super
délicate intéressante et tout ce qu'on
veut
qui encore sort de champ d'expertisé
mais la plupart des expérimentations qui
sont faites aujourd'hui sont faites pour
des des produits ménagers dé des
maladies par exemple on bouffe trop on à
la première cause une des premières
causes de mortalité c'est les maladies
cardiovasculaires de la grèce donc trop
manger de produits animaux notamment et
donc ça fait plein de maladies et après
on fait des expérimentations sur les
animaux pour essayer de soigner les gens
qui boivent trop d'animaux être comme ça
donc il ya tellement de choses qu'on
peut faire c'est à dire que souvent les
gens qui utilisent d'animaux essaye de
nous mettre dans un débat de dire c'est
le choix entre l'un entre l'animal et
l'être
l'animal non humains et l'être humain et
que du coup c'est comme si on était dans
un bateau et que et que
le truc du tramway là tu vois où tu des
villes
le tramway un aiguillage et soit tu vas
sur des animaux se base sur des humains
comme si on était dans cette position là
alors qu'on n'est pas dans cette
position sur l'expérience
expérimentations animales
c'est faux il ya plein de scandales qui
sont sortis sur des médicaments quand et
testés sur les animaux et tout apprécié
on considère que l'animal dont une en
être non humain peut être dans un
certain rayon un bon modèle de l'être
humain dans des situations où on est
vraiment dans dans des situations de
l'un pour l'autre
la question se pose mais exactement la
même façon que la question se pose avec
des êtres humains c'est à dire si
aujourd'hui le fait d' expérimenter sur
un être humain permettant sauver 10
qu'est ce que tu fais moi j'aimerais
bien voir les gens comment ils
réagissent par rapport à ça c'est de
question qu'on doit se poser on reprend
des trucs bien pauvre du continent mais
même je veux dire même semaine vraie
question c'est une vraie question qui se
pose c'est un médicament sur luc qu'on
voit c'est c'est c'est que c'est des
choses c'est l'utilitarisme c'est entre
deux situations essayer de choisir la
moins pire je trouve que tu vois pas
d'autres d'autres théories aujourd'hui
il ya une déontologie ou l'utilitarisme
moi je suis plutôt utilitariste entre du
situation choisi la moins pire sachant
qu'il n'y a pas de situation où on est
gagnant
tout le monde est gagnant à 100% tout le
temps
alors quid des autres associations pour
interrogation style de l'association 269
life qui va bloquer des abattoirs et
fait des happenings en se marquant au
fer rouge
ouais dates marquent au fer rouge sur la
fesse ou non j'avais moi je suis
douillet et donc je ferais pas mais les
attentes et quand même nom de me faire
remarquer ouais non pas du tout spéciale
dédicace à ma dentiste
je suis heureux sur les autres
associations comme 269 par exemple je
trouve que c'est génial c'est des gens
qui sont ultra motivés qui sont
absolument conscient des enjeux qui a
autour de la question animale de
l'élevage et tout ça qui essayent
quelque chose au départ ce mouvement il
vient de d'israël c'est un veau qui
avait justement une
une identification à une boucle quand
les bovins et qui était qui a été sauvée
libéré par une action commando et qui
avaient ce numéro-là 269 et c'est parti
de là et donc il ya un mouvement très
fort en israël autour de cette question
de la libération animale et ils ont fait
des actions très visuel très
spectaculaire justement de se marquer au
fer rouge pour essayer de d'impacter le
grand public et de dire
que le problème de la question animale
et des animaux c'est pas un problème
accessoires c'est quelque chose qui est
sérieux qui est grave et c'est une façon
de signifier de se marquer de montrer
que on était capable d'aller jusque là
de se marquer dans sa chair pour pour
essayer de faire réagir les gens de
faire un électrochoc et de montrer que
voilà après il ya plein de voix possible
le truc c'est d'être ouvert à ces
différentes voies et de ses devoirs
celle qui fonctionne celle qui
fonctionne pas
et à partir de là je trouve que avec l
214 on essaye quelque chose qui est
moins se mettre en avant mais plutôt de
montrer la question animale la violence
qui exerçait sur les animaux et les gens
se démerdent avec ça non mais c'est vrai
je veux dire quand on montrait des
images d'abattoirs ont fait pas une
garde et c'est bien de vous parce que
pour vous réaliser l'intégralité des
vidéos faut quand même sacrément est
accroché il faut vraiment envie d'aller
voir les choses au fond d ouais mais on
s'est aperçu que quand on faisait des
actions type pitard on va dire pour une
autre association céder la peinture
rouge sur les forces et ils font plein
de choses et à tapeta ils font plein de
choses c'est une grosse association aux
états unis mais ils font beaucoup de
choses où il met en scène les militants
des militants se fait dès des gens dans
des barquettes de viande des humains
dans des barquettes pour essayer de
faire réfléchir déclenché l'internet un
seul et on s'aperçoit peut-être c'est
une bonne stratégie pam on a
l'impression que le jeu après de
l'opinion publique et des médias est
ressassé de deux d'avoir un discours sur
l'action militante en elle-même est la
question animale a tendance à passer au
second plan
on peut peut-être avoir cette question
là avec les femen sur le mouvement
féministe
est ce qu'à un moment donné on voit
l'action et la question du féminisme
peut avoir tendance contre-productif
peut-être pas être compréhensif mais à
passer au second plan
en tout cas et c'est ça que je dire
second plan et quand on sait quand on
montre des images d'un petit élevage
d'un petit abattoir parce qu'on a faits
au vigan et ont fait pas de
reconstitution
les gens ils voient les images elles
sont dures elles sont choquantes ya la
violence il ya ça saigne les animaux
sont voient leurs réactions comme tu
disais tout à l'heure de peur de stress
est là on n'a plus l'excusé de
l'abattage industriel
on a pu les excuses des grosse cadence
on n'a plus l'excusé des militants
extrémistes qui veulent nous imposer
quelque chose tout les trucs qui arrive
qui viennent parasiter le débat et
autour de la question animale
et est du coup écarté et on a
l'impression que c'est une voie
intéressante à creuser et c'est la voix
sur lequel on va rester pour le moment
mais que d'autres me d'autres gens
essayent de se démener bouger leur cul
pour aller bloquer dans un abattoir
parce qu'ils pensent que c'est une bonne
façon de faire va je trouve que chapeau
à eux parce qu'ils prennent des risques
qu'ils prennent des procédés prennent
des amendes et ils le font pas pour
gagner rien du tout ils vont peut-être
s'endetter à vie et que et moi j'ai pas
ajuster sa le moins pour moi ma ligne
rouge c'est la violence donc c'est un
mouvement qui est non violent ils se
disent ils ils sont débarqués par les
flics on se faisait désirer
ils ont aucune violence sur les employés
d'abattoirs donc il essaie comme nous de
d'alimenter un débat et tant mieux qu'il
y ait plusieurs assauts une
complémentarité de ses assauts
est ce que tu as été voir les leaders de
des religions pour parler du problème
les religions mais là nous d'un copain
qui s'appelle jacques blamont qu'il
fondateur du programme spatial français
qui a écrit un bouquin qui s'appelle
introduction au siècle des menaces et il
s'est rendu compte que tu vas manger de
la viande ça tapait vraiment dans les
fondamentaux de soutenabilité de notre
société que l'on allait droit dans le
mur sur les questions de la plastique de
fond c'est à tout un tas de choses et il
s'est dit autant aller voir les leaders
de la meilleure propagande qui existe
depuis les deux mille dernières années
on leur demande de faire passer à leurs
clients le fait de manger un peu moins
de viande parce que sinon c'était
compliqué il a été voir le pape par
l'intermédiaire du cardinal noir parce
que toi tu as eu cette idée aussi
d'aller voir les leaders religieux
ouais ouais alors ouais on l'a eu on l'a
eu et notamment avec la question du foie
gras moment donné parce que la filière a
eu d'autres et diecky des queues de
propulser c'est un martin comme patron
une fois va parce que c'était en
novembre et que ça les arrangeait bien
pour relancer la saison du foie gras de
l'avancé un peu
parce que comme on sait que la
consommation de foie gras elle se fait
surtout sur les fêtes de fin d'année au
mois de décembre
donc ils sont dit merde il faudrait
qu'on arrive et qu'on arrive à mettre du
foie gras plutôt dans les supermarchés
et donc on va faire une opération
marketing
on va dire que saint martin parce que
c'est au 11 novembre je crois enfin fin
novembre c'était pas mal comme date
et puis je crois qu'il s'est caché dans
un troupeau d'oies un moment donné ou
associations au foie gras deçà tiens on
va le progression il est surtout coupé
sa cup pour donner un sens à alors quand
on pense à l'histoire de saint martin
des pauvres qu'il était restée avec
lorient ouais hélas aujourd'hui penser
qu'il y associer utilisés
instrumentalisés par l'industrie les
foies gras et donc on avait écrit au
pape au machin tout ça pourquoi il ya
une position de l'héliski dedans ça
c'est un peu abusé là votre truc coupé
sa cape romaine dont il a coupé le
couvre- le couvre dos de son cheval
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas droit de
couper sa cape messages parlent contre
la communauté
il a coupé sa propre cap parce que la
cape promène était propriété de l'armée
ouais donc il a donné un bout de
cinquième point pour le pouvoir et pas
spolier la règle et donc du coup voilà
on a fait ces démarches là mais par
exemple on est aussi en contact avec
fateh kimouche qui s'occupe du site
alcante ce qui est un des plus gros
sites un des petites plus est plus gros
et plus gros influenceurs des
consommateurs musulmans qui relaye
souvent nos enquêtes qui est très pro
animaux sauf sur la question de
l'abattage sans étourdissement mais sur
le reste sur les modes de production
aujourd'hui même sur la promotion du
végétarisme et tout ça donc je pense que
il ya vraiment quelque chose à faire de
ce côté là après moi j'irai vous avez
été voir un peu d'eau cacher oui enfin
cacher c'est un mouvement qui est très
très fort
en israël le mouvement vegan flirte avec
les 10% il ya des choses qui sont très
très fort donc voilà il ya des choses
qui sont après ils sont le mouvement en
france et très crispée sur cette
question là chez sita afin de de tuer
les animaux sans étourdissement ils sont
très attachés à sa plus que le cacher
que le halal donc assez cette question
là qu'il ya un sujet mais je trouve que
c'est il faut aller voir aussi les
autres sujets parce qu'on a tendance à
focaliser sur cette question là par
exemple sur sur le sur le halal on
focalise sur la question au moment de la
mise à mort des animaux mais au niveau à
la l'on doit par exemple consommer des
animaux qui sont sains et je trouve que
par exemple tous les animaux tous les
poulets qui viennent de l'élevage
intensif devraient pas être considérées
comme halal ça serait bien que les
représentants des religieux puissent
aussi est critiquée et se positionner
sur la question de l'élevage intensif
parce que c'est pas mal je suis désolé
un poulet est un poulet doux poulet kfc
et tout ça c'est pas halal je veux dire
si on suit les préceptes de la religion
à la il n'y a pas que les questions de
l'abattage et la question avant quoi
c'est voir le sujet par le petit bout de
la lorgnette et ce qui se passe sur un
truc et il ya des gens il ya musulmans
qui sont tout à fait d'accord avec cette
question là donc exactement comme
l'alliance avec hugo desnoyer sur la
question le boucher je trouve qu'on
aurait énormément à gagner à aller
chercher chez les musulmans les gens qui
sont progresser sur ces questions la
dernière question est ce que là il fait
quand même
22h50 bientôt 10h45 - 14 petit veau sur
les poissons ou point d'interrogation
vous ne faites pas de vidéo sur
issus des fermes d'aquaculture choses
comme ça et ensuite la dernière question
jeu tout de suite cdc un conseil pour le
jeu de génération sur les poissons
c'est un truc où on est totalement
incohérent dans l'association quoi c'est
à dire que c'est la priorité absolue les
poissons les gens baissent leur
consommation de produits animaux et
souvent transfert sur le poisson c'est
1000 milliards de poissons qui sont tués
chaque année c'est une estimation parce
qu'on n'a pas cédé tonnage
voilà les poissons s'aperçoit que haut
niveau et aux logiques pareil la
souffrance maintenant à la verrez ça
dépasse et super large aussi les
poissons mais un faisceau aujourd'hui de
choses qui montrent que le poisson est
intelligent je suis aussi de la plongée
depuis le poisson c'est trop large
mais dans les poissons il ya deux façons
d aborder ils ont des rapports entre les
plus en plus évidents flagrant et tout
ce qu'on veut et nous on n'a rien fait
dedans donc on est on est totalement pas
cohérent et tout ça donc on va y aller
on va y aller mais je pense qu'au départ
c'était l'idée sûrement fosse est pas
terrible de dire que les gens allaient
être moins touchée par les poissons que
par des bovins par exemple parce que
l'on fait une hiérarchie ou si au niveau
des animaux et comme le poisson n'ont
pas de très peu de d'expressions
faciales
il n'y a pas la question du centre ça
c'était c'était prendre un peu le
problème par la face nord est où mais je
pense que c'est pas tout à fait vrai
pour avoir vu des vidéos d'autres
associations américaines qui ont déjà
fait des choses dessus comme mercy for
animals par exemple qui sont faits des
images sur des bateaux
c'est ultra gore de voir des filets de
pêche qui remonte des vessies natatoires
des yeux qui sont allés orbite et de
voir la gueule agonie des poissons en
plus on sait pas les étourdir c'est pas
les abattre ça peut durer les poissons y
mettre les poissons dans les cales de
bateaux sur deux sur de la glace
donc ils prolongent leur agonie pendant
des heures donc c'est un sujet mais
énorme quoi c'est comme la question de
la prédation mais voilà c'est c'est le
sujet à venir ces cas un conseil pour
les jeunes générations
je sais qu'à derna fois j'étais très
embêté avec cette question et je suis
toujours ultra en b tech cette question
à cause de la positionnement que j'ai
pas envie d'être au top jeunes
générations pas jeunes générations je
suis pas je n'ai pas de conseils
spécifiques d'autre que de s'informer
mais c'est pas spécifique aux jeunes
générations qu'est ce que je pourrais
dire qu'ils soient spécifiques en quoi
les générations sont spécifiques par
rapport à d'autres gens c'est peut-être
qu'ils sont c'est un espoir plutôt qu'un
conseil quoi c'est à dire que les jeunes
générations au moins ont plus facile de
faire marche arrière de changer de
changer de régime alimentaire des
que quelqu'un qui va avoir consommé les
produits animaux qui va se trouver
toutes les excuses du monde a continué à
rien changé dans sa vie
donc les jeunes générations sont plus
mobiles et par rapport à ça sont les
gens qui vont donc plus changer de
d'attitude se remettre en question et je
suis pas j'ai pas envie d'avoir des
considérer différemment je j'ai du mal
en fait avec cette question conseils
pour tout le monde que sa caisse
conseils pour tout le monde c'est
d'essayer d'être d'être honnête avec soi
même et ça c'est super compliqué cette
histoire ce truc de déconstruction être
de voir la d'être honnête avec soi-même
de pas forcément juger les autres par
leur comportement parce que ils sont pas
allées aussi loin qu'on imagine soi même
feint d'être bienveillant enfin je
trouve que c'est la bienveillance en
général et je pense que ça ça fait
avancer beaucoup plus et c'est courageux
d'être bienveillant dans notre monde
des fois c'est plus facile d'être d'être
virée dans n'avoir rien à péter d'être
être viril en avoir un régime quoi que
ce soit oui pardon pour les galeries les
pays où il ya des on voit sur la
consommation de viande
la question de la virilité quelque chose
de fort quoi c'est la question de viande
rouge
beaucoup plus consommé par les hommes
que par les femmes qui vont plus se
mettre sur la question des viandes
blanches et il ya pas mal aux théories
qui disent que la consommation de la
viande c'est aussi une façon de
réaffirmer sa domination
je sais pas quel crédit faut apporter à
ça mais quand on voit les comportements
ouais ça ne s'est pas totalement déconne
on peut pas dire non plus qu'on mange de
la viande juste pour dominer mer il ya
quelque chose qu'on peut creuser là
dedans
voilà pourquoi pas mais en tout cas la
bienveillance en général je souffre
c'est une attitude à cultiver au maximum
sébastien merci merci beaucoup
et bon courage avec 214 vous voulez on
en profite pour remercier tous nos
tipper toute notre communauté nous
soutenir c'est grâce à elle qu'on arrive
à faire des vidéos comme ça merci merci
super de le confort de pouvoir discuter
échanges devraient assez c'est
inestimable et c'est internet c'est
génial pour ça et donc il faut préserver
internet et se battre pour garder la
neutralité du net et tout ce qu'on veut
parce que c'est un disposons toujours il
faut pas que que l'industrie remettent
la main là dessus ce qu'ils ont perdu la
main là dessus parce que l'argent ils
pouvaient l'investir dans le dans les
campagnes de pub et tout ça et
aujourd'hui c'est un vrai contre-pouvoir
il faut qu'on se batte pour internet et
et c'est cardio existe grâce à internet
quoi existerait pas autrement suggère
bonne soirée
merci à tout le monde un groupe au
groupe
[Musique]
non